so you know I was a grad student forever
basically I was in grad school for seven
almost seven years I got two PhDs in the
process but I was aggressive for a long
time and I got used to the lifestyle of
a grad student and when when I finished
and I moved to Boston we moved to Boston
and the biggest mistake I did was that I
was so used to living on a PhD student
salary that I couldn't stomach the idea
of a getting getting an apartment in the
size that would actually be good for us
so the problem is we we moved from North
Carolina to Cambridge where for the
first two months we couldn't believe
this were the prices of houses right we
were used to paying North Carolina
prices they were taking us to all these
things with for sure they're hiding
something these are good for tourists
right tourist traps took us two months
to realize what what the price that
really were of houses and we could have
afforded something that would be
reasonable for us but but I couldn't
bring myself to that I couldn't bring
myself for that and we ended buying an
apartment it was too small it was great
for us when we were a couple but very
quickly we had we had the kid and then
we had to move and this was of course
the transaction cost of moving
apartments it was very high so if I only
could stomach early on and to buy a
bigger place we wouldn't have had to do
this double double move and the other
thing that has happened recently is this
look I have to say that this financial
recession has been very good for my
field right for a long time we would say
all people are irrational they make
mistakes and people say oh I see acses
these are undergrads who make mistakes
professional people who get paid a lot
of money in a competitive environment of
the market place will never make this
mistake so all of a sudden we were
vindicated and we have a heyday my book
is doing where all right people invite
me to give talks life is quite good on
this side it's no consolation for
anything but you know at least somebody
is benefiting from this and and when the
recession hit for the first time
name in ten years we decided to go on
vacation now we go on vacation for
nighttime but we always go to see family
we've got to see my family in Israel or
my wife's family in India we don't
really do vacation vacation just just us
and we decided to go on vacation and we
decided just when the recession kind of
hit and in the reality is that vacations
became cheaper we could have gone to a
great vacation to do it but we also felt
very guilty spending the money the
uncertainty the questions about it all
of it was very confusing and we really
felt better now the reality is we were
doing okay we have a long time until
retirement whatever we lost in the stock
market doesn't really come to play for
another thirty years we have tenured
track you know we're tenured professors
that the odds that we would lose our job
is very low from all the people in the
world we're relatively secure in our
jobs but nevertheless we felt bad about
it and we kind of downgraded our
vacation to a big to a big degree and it
was great I mean we had a great time but
but we should have done the other thing
we just felt really guilty with this
economic recession and spending money on
vacation